there is transformation taking place in
Africa sub-saharan Africa is now home to
seven of the fastest growing economies
in the world but Africa will be the next
gross pole of the global economy what
more needs to be done as a continent how
do we deal with our resources the
building's answer an offical you decide
energy is the reason for subdued we
should invest in education for more
change in ventures coming from Africa
what can Africa do different
aleutians ma ana freak dependable
communities are freakin we will be
bringing together seven hundred leaders
on government business civil society and
academia from across the continent and
the rest of the world to shape Africa's
transformation
you